fox's bill malugen has watched this
happen for months he's on the border
right now
we're happy to have him hey bill
hey tucker good evening to you so look
for the past several months now we've
heard the biden administration claim
that progress extreme progress has been
made down here at the border but that's
just not squaring up with what we're
seeing on the ground we want to show you
this remarkable drone video we shot
today with our crew up in del rio take a
look at this staggering footage what
you're looking at here is the
international bridge in del rio we first
showed this to you last night well it
has gotten significantly worse what
you're looking at is sources are telling
me upwards of 10 000 migrants waiting
underneath that bridge right now after
they crossed illegally into the united
states why are they waiting there well
what i'm being told is border patrol
holding facilities in the area are
completely over capacity and border
patrol agents are completely overwhelmed
there's just nowhere for these people to
go right now they're free to go they're
not being detained right now they're
just kind of holding themselves under
this bridge waiting to be apprehended by
border patrol as you mentioned border
patrol sources are telling me most of
these migrants are coming in from haiti
there are also some from cuba and
venezuela as well but this is just a
horrible situation down there and our
border agents need a lot of help
consider yesterday morning there were
only 4 000 migrants under that bridge
now i'm told it's well over 10 000 so in
a span of just over 24 hours those
numbers have doubled and it's not
getting any better those migrants keep
streaming across they just walk across
the rio grande on a dam they walk a dirt
path and more and more are showing up to
that bridge by the hour it's getting
worse by the day literally by the hour
we want to point out something we've
been using our drone to show everybody
these remarkable pictures you can see
the video we got on the ground from some
sources who are leaking stuff to us as
well
we just learned that the faa has put out
a temporary flight restriction a tfr in
the area immediately around the port of
entry where that bridge is what does
that mean it means our drone can no
longer fly and show those images it's a
two-week tfr and according to the faa
it's for special security reasons we've
reached out to the faa to get a little
clarification on what the heck that
means the timing on this the location a
little bit curious i just want to point
out fox news has been at the border for
the better part of seven months now
we've been using the drone the entire
time it's never been an issue all of a
sudden the last 24 hours we start
showing these images at this bridge and
a tfr goes up we can no longer fly when
we get an update from the faa we'll be
sure to let you know but unfortunately
for those agents on the ground
they're completely overwhelmed they need
some serious help right now and
hopefully they get it from the federal
government we'll send it back to you
that's the first time hearing of this
bill i sincerely and haven't talked to
lawyers but i sincerely hope our company
will ignore the faa they have no right
to shut down news gathering they don't
own the news sorry don't move thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else